dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here there are
so many applications of deep learning I
was really excited to put together a
short but really cool list of some of
the more recent results for you fellow
scholars to enjoy machine learning
provides us an incredible set of tools
if you have a difficult problem at hand
you don't need to handcraft an algorithm
for it it finds out by itself what is
important about the problem and tries to
solve it on its own in many problem
domains they perform better than human
experts what's more some of these
algorithms find out things that you
could earn a PhD with 10 years ago here
goes the first stunning application
toxicity detection for different
chemical structures by means of deep
learning it is so efficient that it
could find toxic properties that
previously required decades of work by
humans who are experts of their field
next one mitosis detection from large
images mitosis means that cell nuclei
are undergoing different transformations
that are quite harmful and quite
difficult to detect the best techniques
out there are using convolutional neural
networks and are outperforming
professional radiologists at their own
task unbelievable Kegel is a company
that is dedicated to connecting
companies with large data sets and data
scientists who write algorithms to
extract insight from all this data if
you take only a brief look you see an
incredibly large swath of applications
for learning algorithms almost all of
these were believed to be only for
humans
very smart humans and learning
algorithms again emerge triumphant on
many of these for instance they have a
great competition where learning
algorithms would read a website and find
out whether paid content is disguised
there is real content
next up on the list hallucination or
sequence generation it looks at
different video games tries to learn how
they work and generates new footage out
of thin air by using a recurrent neural
network
really amazing because of the
imperfection of the 3d scanning
procedures many 3d scanned furnitures
are too noisy to be used as is however
there are techniques to look at these
really noisy models and try to figure
out how they should look by learning the
symmetries and other properties of real
furnitures
these algorithms can also do an
excellent job at predicting how
different fluids behave in time and are
therefore expected to be super useful in
physical simulation in the following
years
and on the list of highly sophisticated
scientific topics there is this
application that can find out what makes
a good selfie and how good your photos
are if you really want to know the truth
here is another application where a
computer algorithm that we call deep
q-learning place pong against itself and
eventually achieves expertise
you
the machines are also grading student
essays at first one would think that
this cannot possibly be a good idea
and as it turns out their judgment is
more consistent with the reference
grades than any of the teachers who were
tested this could be an awesome tool for
saving a lot of time and assisting the
teachers to help their students learn
this kind of blows my mind it would be
great to take a look at an actual data
set if it is public and the issued
grades so if any of you fellow scholars
have seen it somewhere please let me
know in the comment section and these
results are only from the last few years
and it's really just scratching the
surface there are literally hundreds of
more applications we haven't even talked
about we are living extremely exciting
times indeed I am eager to see and
perhaps be a small part of this progress
there are tons of reading and viewing
materials in the description box check
them out thanks for watching and for
your generous support and I'll see you
next time